c'est en juin 15 juin johnny vous quitte
ouais il vous quitte pour nathalie baye
là c'est dur la whey comment vous la
prenez n'apprend pas à la presse quoi
par la pression bah ça se passe pas bien
c'est à 4 avec johnny il a prôné par la
presse que nathalie baye sur le cas des
acquiescements à cataclysme intérieur je
n'y crois pas j'ai du mal à parler à
réagir je suis effondré on n'avait
jamais parlé d'eux enfin d'autres vous
n'avez pas parlé pas ça non voilà je
suis parti je suis parti sur la pointe
des pieds de la même manière quand je
suis rentré dans sa ville mais vous
savez
ce qui me ce qui le caractérise
ac c'est ma discrétion c'est ce qu'on
voit c'est vrai parce que c'est
quelqu'un de très discrètes et je n'aime
pas tout ce qui est on va dire tapage
médiatique que j'avais pas besoin de
faire c'était regardant les johnny 2010
lorsque nous avons divorcé elle n'a pas
essayé de profiter de la situation
avec le recul je m'aperçois qu'elle a
été l'une des femmes les plus dignes de
ma vie ça ça va c'est très très émouvant
et et ça me touche énormément oui ça me
touche énormément ça prouve que cette
histoire a vraiment eu de l'importance
pour lui ça prouve que j'ai été vraiment
une femme à ses côtés et ça m'a
terriblement ému ouais c'est plus
refaire votre vue oui bien sûr
heureusement d'ailleurs
promise ou bien ça a été difficile il
fallu un peu de temps n'oubliez pas
johnny comme ça d'autant que c'est quand
c'est un grand amour et à premières
amours c'est difficile
vous avez oublié de nouvelles de lui
après après j'ai eu des nouvelles de lui
chacun avait refait sa vie et puis comme
par hasard il y avait une boîte
pas très loin de rouge habiter où il ya
les très très souvent les boîtes de nuit
le sunshine à saint germain des prés on
me bayle là il apprend que j'habite là
et puis il téléphone dit je peux passer
je vais discuter avec toi et puis on
s'est revus plusieurs fois près ou et
bien sûr quand vous avez vécu comme vous
avez appris la théorie ça a été sa part
de ma vie qui s'est un peu écroulé sa
pan de ma jeunesse c'est normal on
n'oublie pas quelqu'un qu'on a
terriblement et mais c'est difficile
d'autant que johnny t'es quand même
quelqu'un de du camp dit on de dandy
s'effondrer parce que je n'arrivais pas
y croire pour moi johnny et il est
immortel
et puis et puis il restera dans
l'histoire de toute façon c'est à un
monument c'est un monument national
saignant peut pas vous avez essayé de
joindre la famille pour pouvoir assister
aux funérailles
j'ai essayé sept jours de laëtitia j'ai
pas essayé de joie non nous entendu à
sion ou là je ne la connais pas ce jour
j'ai rien à dire là-dessus recettes de
dames chez je la connais même pas eu de
réponse de la famille qui devait être un
peu je pense qu'elle était un sous l'eau
voilà je pense qu'ils avaient d'autres
soucis et d'autres préoccupations à ce
moment là sûrement vous êtes marié
maintenant je suis j'ai été mariée
malheureusement le père de mon fils est
décédé le même jour que johnny
incroyable mais c'est des coïncidences
qui sont absolument hallucinant c'est
incroyable le 11 décembre quand je n'y a
été enterré saint-barthélemy le père de
mon fils décédé et ça a été double peine
pour moi parce que ce sont deux hommes
que j'ai terriblement aimé que qu'on
n'oublie pas donc c'est triste mais ça
n'a pas été facile cette année de
nouveaux locataires au but
c'était horrible cette année 2010 est en
fait c'est une histoire folle par l'amba
écouter ça fait partie de johnny fait
partie des bons moments de ma vie et je
ne peux que lui rendre hommage
merci en tout cas et je trouve que vous
êtes du nom
on